I saw the tube I knew what to do what's  what's so funny guys  you had to be bad yeah classic me I am  there I will never get tired of this  [ __ ] hey Kalin what's up right there  what's that hey you think I'm I'm funny  right oh yeah  I mean you're not a Snapple cap funny  but I do laugh at you a lot no thanks  Elliot  what the hell but nothing it's just a  joke right goob  that's disgusting yeah Elliot that's not  cool  whispering tube that's like sexual no no  it's a non sequitur just like zucchini  Elliot zucchinis are funny like  eggplants or cucumbers a rhubarb yeah  but those are all things you can like  stick into rhubarb what okay fine look I  can fix this or just a joke here I can  fix this  why did the rabbi say to the magician oh  come on Charley's Jewish Peruvian  thought more of you I know I love Jewish  things okay let me try again okay knock  knock who's there  penis roll-on that's the thing Oh  okay fine here here zucchini kill  squash